I'm here in San Francisco with Lucas to
plan who's the CEO and founder of
clincal so can you explain to me a
little bit what clincal is yeah sure so
clincal is a digital wallet for your
day-to-day transactions and what does
that mean sort of on from for me as a
consumer sure so our goal is to build
the world's finest serious contender to
cashing cards we've seen software change
industry after industry over the past 20
years I don't use them encyclopedias you
Google right I don't like letters I've
email on Facebook and one of the we use
- but you still use cash and you still
use you know a piece of plastic with 16
digits and so the vision for this
company is to basically take how we
transact and move that from offline to
online and so this vision is really sort
of caught on in a big way out here so
you've had some give some really
high-profile backers Jim Brier Peter
Thiel
you raised a lot of money and hired a
lot of people really fast so does that
feel like a lot of pressure or you just
like excited to be going for the ride
you know I'm mostly excited I was
actually watching a YouTube video of
Nick Saban who is the coach of the
Alabama football just lost the Auburn
and just disappointed yeah but he was
saying something which really caught my
attention which is when we play football
we don't look at the scoreboard and the
philosophy for his team is you know
every 30 seconds you know put your head
down and do the best job you can on that
play and you know I found if you let the
you know the the pressure and the stress
and expectations you know get to you
just can't deliver and so my goal has
been each play to play it as best I can
you know come in each day at work not
worrying about yesterday not worrying
about tomorrow but worrying about today
and so that's been the way I've kind of
dealt with it and you also have you
brought in some help so you hired
CEO the former CEO of Netflix yes CFO
sorry Barry McCarthy and and that must
be a relief and a help and how do you
guys work together and how does that
work yeah so I brought Barry on as a
trusted business partner he has a
tremendous amount of experience and
expertise in business and just as
important he's an incredibly high
integrity person and also culturally
we're on the same page I don't know if
you're familiar with the Netflix culture
deck and kind of the the culture but you
don't have to explain that yeah so um
it's funny Silicon Valley company takes
on a personality of its own a lot like
you know a human being would have and I
think what Reed has done in Netflix is
is really incredible and you know you
can google it but there's a number of
tenants which you know we believe in
that the Netflix believed in and we're
trying to bring here to clincal let's
talk a little bit about Stanford
University and you came out of Stanford
you dropped out at Stanford I finished
my degree oh okay so that's awesome
minorities didn't didn't make it so you
graduated yeah what is it about the you
know so many of the people that I'm out
here talking to you and they're doing
really amazing things are coming out of
Stanford and it's a great school but
they're actually many great schools what
do you think it is about that university
that really sort of spawns this
entrepreneurial sort of culture right
well I think it starts with who a plus
because really smart people want to be
around other really smart people and so
I think you have to tease out whether
it's causation or correlation but you
generally have people who want to be
entrepreneurial entrepreneurial apply
and go there and then once you get there
that spark is really hopefully
transformed into fire by virtue of the
other people who are there the
that are there and the resources that
the university provides and so I'm
really fortunate to have been a part of
that and certainly feel very lucky so if
we fast forward five years Lucas where
are you gonna be here and Matt is kinkle
gonna completely or clincal I'm sorry
Klee we're gonna completely replace cash
or or what would we be talking about in
five years from now yeah so I think the
first thing to realize is that really
big and hard change doesn't happen
overnight
and and you're a big baby we're a big
big but you know Silicon Valley has I
think a really short attention span and
you know it's hey there's this new
startup and there's you know twenty kids
working on it and like tomorrow they're
gonna change how the entire monetary
system works and maybe that's not that's
no pressure right right well maybe
that's how it is in LA and Hollywood
movies but it takes a lot of work right
and when you think about causing real
change especially in industries which
haven't had much change there's serious
things you have to think about security
privacy uptime reliability I mean the
list goes on and on and so there's
there's a lot of things that we think
about we know we take what we're doing
pretty seriously because it's people's
money and so I think our goal isn't to
completely wipe out cash and cards and
you know five years but it's to begin
this revolution and maybe it'll take
five years maybe it'll take ten years
but I think that the key is to be
marching in the right direction as
opposed to staying stagnant